unterwegs mit der präsenz einheit der
berliner polizei in kreuzberg ziel heute
der görlitzer park dort wo eigentlich
kinder spielen sollten verkaufen dealer
drogen aller art heute einsatz mit
spürhunden die finden was polizisten
nicht so leicht entdecken sollen diesmal
cannabis tüten mit hohem thc gehalten
fachjargon bombe hier im park verkaufen
vor allem migranten aus afrika den stoff
an jeden der zahlt nach angaben der
polizei sind in berlin rund 60 prozent
der tatverdächtigen drogendealer aus
ländern die einsatztruppe kontrolliert
wieder wird ein schwarzer abgeführt und
als wenige straßen weiter
ein mutmaßlicher dealer verhaftet wird
kommen sofort die vorwürfe
rachel profiling und polizeigewalt
[Musik]
ja
jeden tag gehe das so
insbesondere wir haben dann hier
schwierigkeiten wenn dann halt menschen
sich menschen an sammeln die dann nicht
wissen was hier passiert und einfach nur
aufgrund natürlich der jetzigen
situation auf der ganzen welt ist ja
logisch dann einfach uns auch
insbesondere rassismus vorwerfen
und damit ist es halt schwierig
umzugehen dann in diesem moment weil wir
sind angehalten die maßnahme dann erst
mal durchzuführen und dann im anschluss
eventuell dann das auch mit den
bürgerinnen und bürgern zu klären was
halt auch letztendlich passiert es immer
öfter stellen passanten handy videos ins
netz oft ohne zusammenhang dafür mit
klarer botschaft
[ __ ] etwas für missgeburten das
ist richtig dass und demokratie manch
einer scheint nicht zu wissen wo in der
demokratie das gewaltmonopol liegt ein
polizeibeamter muss jederzeit in der
lage sein erstens die rechtliche
grundlage anzugeben auf der er hier
gerade handelt und zweitens den anlass
der maßnahme zu erklären
und wenn der anlass so aussieht dass man
weiß dass eine bestimmte klientel ein
bestimmtes milieu ein bestimmter teil
der gesellschaft beispielsweise im park
iks mit drogen handelt und dieser
drogenhandel dort von dieser gruppe
dominiert wird
dann ist eine kontrolle dieser gruppe
dort kein racial profiling
was wie soll das denn komme ich erwarte
sogar von der polizei dass die profiling
betreibt profiling ist klassische
polizeiarbeit das ist tagesgeschäft ich
muss ein profil bilden ist unser
tagesgeschäft eines
sozialwissenschaftlers ich bilde profile
ich musste ja wissen worum es geht ich
muss ja wissen von wem ich spreche
sechster juni 2020 eine demonstration in
berlin gegen rassismus anlass die
tödlichen attacken von us polizisten
gegen den schwarzen george floyd
zunächst verläuft die demo friedlich
rund eine stunde nach ende der
kundgebung ein schwarzer demonstrant
liegt am boden
polizisten über ihm als die bilder
öffentlich werden ist die aufregung groß
gewalt und rassismus bei der berliner
polizei
die wehrt sich gegen den vorwurf also
wir haben spezielle nach der nach der
demo zu george leute in berlin haben wir
videos gesehen von festnahmen so und
dann drücken drei polizisten einen
schwarzen mann auf den boden so und
sofort äußern sich auch führende
bundespolitiker hat die berliner polizei
nichts gelernt welche profiling durch
die berliner polizei dass der mann
vorher eine viertelstunde lang die
kollegen massiv beleidigt hat sie
wegschubsen wollte dass er irgendwann
auf den boden gedrückt wird das gehört
eben dazu
also polizei ist dazu legitimiert gewalt
anzuwenden und sie muss es auch machen
um straftaten zu arten und zurück am
kottbusser tor kurze verfolgungsjagd
dann schnappen sie einen mutmaßlichen
dealer bevor er flüchten kann mit einem
elektro roller
der verdächtige ein polizeibekannter
drogenkurier diesmal finden die beamten
bei dem rumänen eine größere menge
kokain und 450 euro
die polizisten ahnen morgen wird er
wahrscheinlich wieder hier stehen
eine etage tiefer in der berliner u-bahn
nächste kontrolle nächster funde dieser
mann hat drogen in den taschen dazu ein
messer alltag für die beamten im radio
am kottbusser tor ist glaube ich die
quote warben auch extrem getrieben was
gewaltdelikte an geht um das jetzt nicht
gegenüber der polizei sondern auch
gegenüber dem bürger und von daher ist
das potenzial extrem hoch und dann
natürlich auch uns wenn wir maßnahmen
treffen
dass man rechnen müssen
laut bundeskriminalamt gab es 2009 10
bundesweit fast 15.000 angriffe auf
polizisten im juni 2020 dann stuttgart
es war heute nacht eine nie dagewesene
dimension von offener gewalt gegen
polizeibeamte und massive
sachbeschädigungen nur einen monat
später ähnliche szene in frankfurt am
main
mehr als die hälfte der tatverdächtigen
hat laut polizei frankfurt
migrationshintergrund
die gewalt richtet sich nicht nur gegen
einsatzkräfte der polizei wir haben
mittlerweile ohnehin so ein bisschen
eine verrohung respekt verluste
gegenüber institutionen und auch gerade
gegen personen aus dem öffentlichen
dienst kommt auch verstärkt zur angriffe
gegen feuerwehrleute gegen
rettungssanitätern beispielsweise berlin
neukölln zwei beamte wollen einen
tatverdächtigen festnehmen der spuk der
polizisten ins gesicht
als der kollege zur festnahme schreiben
will beginnt eine wilde schlägerei
der täter kann später flüchten
angesichts solcher vorfälle seien die
auf pauschal geäußerten
rassismus-vorwürfe für viele polizisten
unverständlichen wir versperren der
debatte nicht und wir sind auch offen
für studien zu wäsche profiligen oder
rassismus innerhalb der polizei man
sollte dann halt gucken wie das
aufgebaut ist also es kann nicht sein
dass man online einträgt ich bin schwarz
ich bin opfer von wäsche profiling
geworden und die polizei hatten
rassismus probleme und den haken runter
und das war's also man sollte es schon
richtig wissenschaftlich begleiten und
vielleicht mehr so eine studie zu
rassismus in unserer gesellschaft viel
weiter reichen wenn man sollte es nicht
nur auf polizei beschränken noch ein
beispiel
hamburg ein junger mann gegen mehrere
polizisten
die wollen seine identität prüfen
der wehrt sich passanten filmen und
mischen sich ein
das weiß ich nicht
wieder wird dem polizisten gewalt und
rassismus vorgeworfen später stellt sich
heraus der junge mann ist immer wieder
ihr roller auf dem bürgersteig gefahren
verwarnungen habe erst ignoriert sagt
und als er wieder ertappt wird habe er
weder seinen ausweis zeigen noch mit auf
die wache kommen wollen
die polizei nicht helfer sondern feind
eine haltung die immer öfter zu
beobachten sei ich bin unabhängig mich
lassen sich das mir von niemandem etwas
sagen
keiner kann mir was ich bin unantastbar
und die natürlich wenn sie bestimmte
soziale medien konsumieren natürlich
hier täglich bestärkt werden ja viele
polizisten seien verunsichert berichtet
ein zivilfahnder die meisten kollegen
haben einfach angst einen fehler zu
machen
da steht nicht mehr der einsatz im
vordergrund sondern die fragen sich
schon vorher
speziell wenn es um menschen mit
migrationshintergrund geht hoffentlich
mache ich keinen fehler
hoffentlich kommt es nicht zu einer
körperlichen auseinandersetzung die dann
noch gefilmt wird dann ist meine
karriere zu ende ehe sie angefangen hat
die einheit am kottbusser tor macht
feierabend morgen wird sie wieder
tatverdächtige kontrollieren die lagen
so gut es geht in berlin für sicherheit
sorgen und ihn aushalten den vorwurf
deutsche polizisten seien vor allem nur
eins gewalttäter und rassisten
[Musik]